doesn't seem fair I've just be that way
I guess give you a walk to the god
Oh
I come from a country that is now
utterly schizophrenic when it comes to
its society its economy its politics
there are definitely two Americas I live
in one one block in Baltimore it is part
of the viable America the American is
connected to a phone economy where
there's a plausible future for the
people born into it about 20 blocks away
is another America entirely it's
astonishing how little we have to do
with each other and yet we live in such
proximity there's no barbed wire around
West Baltimore or any spot more around
chemical the areas that my city that
have been utterly divorced from the
American experience that I'm that I know
but there might as well be if you're
white and you're killed three blocks
from the Hopkins campus all the
detectives in Baltimore are going to be
called in to do everything possible to
solve that murder on the other hand if
you're 18 year old kid shot to death and
the 24 block Edmondson Avenue where
somebody is shot to death once a month
whether they need it or not you know
you're going to get one detective he's
going to give shake the case for
compliments that really speaks to these
sort of two cities getting side by side
where the stakes have been made very
different
Oh